[Musique]
la ligne siegfried
l'ultime rempart
à l'automne 1916 deux ans après le début
de la première guerre mondiale
l'allemagne commence la construction
d'une importante ligne de défense l'asic
fritsch delhoume ou position exprime
les anglais baptisèrent cette ligne de
défense la ligne hindenburg
à la même époque les anglais comme les
français développait une nouvelle arme
capable de facilement percé les lignes
de défense allemande le blindé
en 1938 le même nom fut donné à une
nouvelle structure défensive
officiellement dénommé le mur de l'ouest
en cours de construction le long des
frontières occidentales de l'allemagne
cette ligne cours est approximativement
de l'est de balle jusqu'à qu'armstrong à
l'ouest vers le luxembourg et au nord le
long de la frontière de la belgique et
des pays bas
originellement conçu pour défendre la
région de la sarre récemment ray annexée
elle fut étendue pour devenir la
contrepartie allemande de la ligne
maginot française
chez les alliés cette ligne défensive
reçu le surnom de ligne siegfried
c'était un ensemble de champs de mines
de pièges antichars de barbelés et de
kasma
la propagande nazie élevait ses
fortifications au rang de barrière
infranchissable
restée intacte lors des premières années
de la guerre le mur de l'ouest fut le
bastion de la dernière chance pour les
troupes allemandes face aux armées
alliées
l'idée originale qui a mené à la
construction de ce mur remonte à 1936
lorsque les troupes allemandes ont de
nouveau pénétré en rennais
il y avait alors une double ligne de
défense qui courait sur toute la
longueur de la frontière occidentale de
l'allemagne dans la partie nord de cette
ligne on trouve aussi les barrières
naturelles que sont les rivières heures
et masse et au sud le rhin on savait que
ces rivières ne pourrait pas stopper une
armée mais comment elle pourrait la
retarder suffisamment pour permettre aux
allemands d'acheminer les forces mobiles
de réseaux
le long de la frontière se trouvait
certaines des plus anciennes villes
allemandes déjà fortifie les routes
entre ces villes étaient les points
faibles de ses défenses
chaque ville était protégé par de très
importants champs de mines et des
blockhaus en béton mais la plus grande
efficacité ne résidait ni dans le béton
lit dans les barrières métalliques
mais bien dans la propagande dont il
était l'objet
d'après les nazis le mur de l'ouest
était imprenable même par les sharks il
avait seulement ébréché lors de la
première guerre mondiale
[Musique]
un peu plus à l'intérieur du territoire
se trouvait une seconde ligne de défense
dans laquelle était incorporé les villes
de la vallée du rhin comme cologne
coblence ou karlsruhe
elle était également très bien fortifié
par des champs de mines des pièges
antichars et des casemates
[Musique]
en mai 1938 les grands travaux commencés
hitler avait ordonné que toute la longue
frontière allemande avec la france la
belgique et le luxembourg soient
fortifiées dans les 18 mois
l'homme qui a reçu la mission de
superviser la construction et le travail
des techniciens de la défense militaire
était le dr todd un ingénieur issu d'une
famille de la haute société du sud de
l'allemagne
todd avait peu de contacts avec les
politiciens et les nazis mais était
appréciée d'hitler
et son équipe se mirent au travail
immédiatement récent des plans et des
plannings pour l'immense tâche qui les
attendait
les travaux devraient être finis dans
les 18 mois eton reçu le droit de faire
appel à toutes les ressources que
l'allemagne pouvait offrir
la puissante industrie métallurgique de
la vallée de la ruhr tournait déjà à
plein pour alimenter la nouvelle machine
de guerre d'hitler embauchant de plus en
plus de main-d'oeuvre et réouvrant de
vieilles usines fermées pendant la crise
de 29
il allait devoir produire plus d'un
million de tonnes de métal et d'acier
[Musique]
des forêts furent rasés la fin d'assurer
l'approvisionnement emploi
desrochers furent dynamité pour produire
les 3 millions de tonnes de gravier
nécessaire
[Musique]
et
cinq mille kilomètres de câbles d'acier
furent fabriqués il était destiné à
renforcer les défenses en béton de 3
mètres de largeur dans l'espoir de les
rendre imprenable
[Musique]
la compagnie ferroviaire allemande
faisait circuler plus de 100 trains de
marchandises chaque jour transportant
les matériaux nécessaires aux sites en
compte
[Musique]
des centres de distribution étaient
établis le long du réseau ferroviaire ou
les matériaux été transférée sur des
camions qui continuait le reste du
parcours par la route
pendant sa construction un tiers de la
production totale de ciment produit en
allemagne fut consacrée au mur
occidental
au total 8 millions de tonnes de ciment
ils furent utilisés
des dizaines de milliers de camions fut
réquisitionné dans toute l'allemagne au
plus fort du chantier plus de huit mille
camions transportaient leurs charges aux
différents sites chaque jour
ces camions étaient tous privés mais
leurs propriétaires très peu rémunérés
pour leur utilisation
de nombreux opérateurs tombèrent donc en
faillite juste pour que leurs camions
soit ensuite confisqué
[Musique]
un million de tonnes de bois furent
nécessaires pour le chantier du mur
représentant un volume de 700 8000
mètres cubes
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
3 millions de rouleaux de barbelés
furent dérouler soit mis bout-à-bout
30000 km
[Musique]
on produisait également des centaines de
milliers de poutres d'acier elle devait
supporter les structures et renforcer
les fortifications bétonnée
[Musique]
en dépit de la propagande beaucoup ne
voyaient dans le mur dit clair qu'une
simple marotte car ils se demandaient à
quoi il allait bien pouvoir servir
[Musique]
cependant la construction continue est
un rythme acharné et coûteux mobilisant
de très nombreux travailleurs
[Musique]
de toutes les villes allemandes étaient
venus les travailleurs qualifiés
charpentiers maçons et ingénieurs
heureux de retrouver un travail
c'est ce que la propagande laissé
filtrer
todd avait à sa disposition les énormes
ressources d'une main d'oeuvre peu cher
voire gratuite d'une allemagne qui se
remettait à peine de la crise économique
[Musique]
todd avait rassemblé une main d'oeuvre
constitué de 100 mille techniciens
militaires de 350 mille hommes faisant
partie de l'organisation todt et de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'autres
venus du arbeit dienst la main d'oeuvre
du parti nazi
les travailleurs vivaient dans des camps
établis tout le long de la frontière
dans des zones isolées à la différence
des zones industrielles les frontières
étaient parsemées de petits villages
ruraux qui était là depuis des siècles
en octobre 1938 532000 hommes femmes et
enfants travaillaient sur les
fortifications
cependant ils n'étaient pas tous
volontaires
en un seul jour d'août 1938 nous mille
hommes furent réquisitionnés à berlin et
défier cet ordre aurait signifié au
mieux l'emprisonnement
une entreprise à berlin perd 10 ainsi
400 de ces travailleurs les plus
qualifiés
ils furent tous transportés sur le mur
dans des camions fermé et mise au secret
[Musique]
l'essentiel de la main d'oeuvre était
cependant originaires de la zone
frontalière allemande les jeunes les
vieux les hommes et les femmes
participaient à la construction de la
ligne de défense ils étaient pour la
plupart heureux d'améliorer les maigres
revenus de leur petite ferme car il
travaillait encore avec des méthodes
datant presque du moyen-âge
[Musique]
le mur de l'ouest était en fait le plus
grand programme de construction jamais
entrepris de toute l'histoire alpes
bien que la propagande allemande
prétendit constamment à quel point le
peuple allemand était heureux de
travailler pour les idéaux de la
nouvelle allemagne nazie la réalité
était que l'essentiel de la main
d'oeuvre était réquisitionnée efforcé de
travail
m
on
la rue
[Musique]
l'effort
et
m
[Musique]
or
areva
[Musique]
maintenant
tha
[Musique]
hélas
[Musique]
plus de la moitié de la structure était
souterraine les milliers de casemate
étant relié par une série de passages
enterré et de thunes
le travail était particulièrement
risquée et de nombreux travailleurs
furent tués pendant les années de
construction de ces souterrains
[Musique]
les pyramides de béton étaient appelés
dans de dragons et variaient de 1 à 3
mètres de haut elle était destinée à
arrêter les blindés et disposés par
rangées de cinq tout au long de la ligne
de défense
en 1939 alors que la fin de la période
de construction approcher
un vent de colère souffle est parmi les
travail
ce sont traités comme des forçats
travaillant 15 heures par jour avec des
conditions de glisse en mer et une
récurent insuffisant
les gardes supplémentaires furent amenés
afin d'empêcher les travailleurs de
déclencher une grève générale mais la
colère grondait de plus en plus fort
les mesures furent donc prises pour
améliorer les conditions de travail et
tenir les délais
quiconque avait travaillé durant une
période de 12 mois était autorisé à
rentrer chez lui les épouses étaient
autorisés à venir dans les camps et
bénéficier de billets de train à bas
prix en voyager
et salaires furent augmenter et ceux qui
travaillaient dans les conditions les
plus difficiles reçurent des médailles
ces mesures prises selon les ordres
d'hitler ayant pour objectif de
compléter les défenses à tout prix dans
les délais réussir à calmer les ouvrir
[Musique]
de nombreux travailleurs étaient des
jeunes des arbailles styliste
[Musique]
chaque jeune allemand garçons aux filles
devaient rejoindre cette organisation
dès l'âge de 17 ans pour une durée de
six mois
mais certains volontaires l'intégrer un
peu plus jeunes
ils étaient chargés de creuser les
fondations d'installer les pièges anti
chars et de tirs et les barbus
en août 1939 le pari avait été tenue le
mur de l'ouest était terminée
en à peine plus d'une année il avait
bâti une monumentale construction de
béton d'acier et de bois qui s'étalait
le long des frontières occidentales de
l'allemagne tel un immense serpent
[Applaudissements]
le mur faisait 640 km de long
il traverse l allemagne sur toute sa
longueur et sur 4 kilomètres de large
14000 bon coeur et autres casemate
avaient été construits reliés par un
réseau de routes bétonnées
[Musique]
son coût s'élevait à 3 milliards et demi
de deutsche mark
quelles que soient les avis émis à
propos de la fiabilité de ces nouvelles
fortifications
hitler avait sa propre opinion
elle faisait partie de son grand plan
il savait qu'elle lui assurer une totale
liberté d'action vers l'est ce dont ils
avaient besoin pour les actions qu'il
programmait en pologne et en
tchécoslovaquie
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
grâce à la protection qui se mure fret à
l'ouest
l'allemagne n'avait pas peur d'une
guerre sur deux fronts
raison des différents échecs militaires
passent
[Musique]
hitler l'avait fait remarquer alain de
ses généraux
croyez-moi général je suis le plus grand
constructeur de fortification de tous
les temps
j'ai construit le mur de l'ouest
[Musique]
en grande bretagne en amérique ce
nouveau mur de béton gris qui était
apparu presque soudainement traversant
le milieu de l'europe fut surnommé avec
ironie la ligne aix reid
[Musique]
elle devint le sujet d'une chanson qui
fut l'un des hits musicaux de 1939
[Musique]
trois financeurs
hilal
mamma mia
[Musique]
jean en asie
la
machine taillée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trois thés cafés
les anglais puis les américains allaient
entrer en guerre en reprenant les
couplet et le refrain de cette chanson
oui il allait étendre leur linge sur la
ligne siegfried
si la ligne siegfried était encore là
cependant bien tristement plus de cent
mille de ces jeunes soldats anglais
français canadiens et américains qui
marchait gaiement vers la guerre avec
cette chanson aux lèvres allait mourir
avant d'atteindre ces bunkers d'acier et
de béton
un nombre équivalent de jeunes soldats
allemands allaient subir le même sort en
et défendant
[Musique]
chaque bunker faisait 7 m de large et
six mètres de haut les murs et le
plafond pouvaient atteindre jusqu'à 3
mètres d'épaisseur
chaque bunker hébergeait une section de
14 hommes
ses fortifications et équipements
germanique presque spartiates
les casemates étaient équipés de
mitrailleuses et de canons de 37 mm le
mur était prêt tel un serpent attendant
d'attraper sa foi et de l'achever par
une morsure mortelle
après son attaque contre la pologne et
ses échecs dans ses tentatives de paix
avec les pays de l'ouest ce mur donnait
à hitler le temps de planifier son
attaque vers l'ouest en 1940 il n'avait
plus besoin de ce qu
il était désormais le maître de l'europe
de l'ouest
le mur fut abandonné ses bunkers scellé
au début de 1944 les allemands
comprirent que l'invasion était
inévitable et ils regardèrent du côté du
mur de l'ouest pour empêcher les alliés
d'entrée en allemagne à l'été 1944 le
sud de l'angleterre déborder d'hommes et
de matériel
l'amérique avait dépêché plus de 950
mille soldats ainsi qu un nombre énorme
de camions de véhicules blindés de chars
et de matériel divers
sur les routes du kent des camions ont
formé un convoi sans fin dom et de
machines
c'était le début de la plus grande
opération amphibie jamais entreprise
dans toute l'histoire de la guerre
5000 navire accompagnée de milliers
d'embarcations plus petit appuyée par
plus de 11 cents avions étaient sur le
point de déposer près de deux cent mille
hommes contre le mur de l'atlantique
derrière lequel les 70 vision du
maréchal von rundstedt attendait
une fois les plages de normandie
conquise l'opération avait alors permis
à plus de deux millions de soldats
anglais américains et du commonwealth de
marcher sur leurs hommes
l'objectif était simple la libération de
l'europe et la défaite de l'allemagne
nazie
l'assaut fut lancée le 6 juin 1944 un
jour qui restera à jamais célèbre sous
le nom de dj
les jours qui suivirent le débarquement
de furieux combats se déroulaient entre
les alliés qui cherchaient à sécuriser
leur tête de pont et les allemands qui
tentaient de les en empêcher
les troupes étaient acheminés à travers
la manche et la pénétration à
l'intérieur des terres commençait en
normandie
la troisième armée us passa en bretagne
puis au sud de la loire et pendant le
même temps la première armée avançaient
vers la ville de vire tandis que la
seconde armée britannique lançaient un
assaut contre villers bocage
la résistance allemande fut acharnée ils
lancèrent contre attaque sur contre
attaque
il est très inquiet ordonna à ses
généraux de contenir les amis
vers la fin du mois de juillet la tacc
alliés c'est un principe 2 million
d'hommes avaient débarqué et reprenait
ville après ville aux troupes ennemies
morceau par morceau la france est libéré
par les alliés les armées d'hitler se
trouvait forcés de battre en retraite
face à l'avancée alliés et à sa
puissance les allemands n'avaient
d'autre choix que de reculer ou de
risquer d'être encerclés par les pièges
qui leur était tendu
toute la france résonnait de cris de
joie après cinq ans où l'horreur de
l'occupation nazie
enfin les alliés arriver
[Musique]
on
non
alors
[Musique]
le 25 août deux mois et demi après le
début de l'attaqué contre la forteresse
europe les alliés en traînant par
l'essentiel de la garnison allemande
avait battu en retraite mais il reste
encore bien des poches de résistance les
snipers qui se tenait dans quelques
immeubles furent forcés de se rendre où
furent éliminés
alors que les colonnes de soldats us
faisaient leur entrée triomphante la
ville était submergé par la joie et
l'émotion des parisiens
enfin libre après cinq ans d'occupation
[Applaudissements]
le 3 septembre c'était au tour de
bruxelles d'être libéré cette fois par
la division blindée de la british garde
les allemands reculent et maintenant à
l'intérieur de leur propre pays
[Musique]
si l'allemagne devait rester aux mains
des nazis la ligne siegfried allait être
le dernier rempart
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les alliés avaient pourtant un problème
les approvisionnements avaient du mal à
parvenir aux soldats de première ligne
les colonnes de soutien n'arrivais pas à
suivre le rythme de l'avancé avec pour
conséquence des pénuries de nourriture
de carburant et de munitions
[Musique]
à mi septembre les alliés approchait des
défenses occidentale du mur entre
aix-la-chapelle et gelsenkirchen
ligne siegfried est hélas de vente
les casemates lourdement fortifiée et se
passer de 150 mètres semble est
imprenable
je
vous
la phase suivante de l'opération
commencée
[Musique]
si les alliés ne pouvait pas percer la
ligne siegfried alors il était prévu de
la contourner par le nord
trois divisions aéroportées devait
prendre les ponts de eindhoven de grave
et de nimègue ainsi que sur le rhin à
arnhem
une division supplémentaire devait être
aligné avec les troupes aéroportées pour
les épauler une fois que les ponts
serait pris
[Musique]
les deux premiers assauts aggravé
eindhoven furent couronnés de succès
mais le troisième tenté pour sécuriser
un côté du coin d'arnhem rencontre à une
sévère résistance
la première division aéroporté
britannique avec dix mille hommes
s'accrochait désespérément sur la partie
nord
mais fut incapable de déloger des
allemands de la rive sud
le conte routier restait intacte mais
les allemands par vaart à détruire le
pont ferroviaire
2 division de panzers rendirent
impossible l'arrivée des renforts
aligner les anglais furent littéralement
cloué sur place
handicapé par des communications radio
difficiles par le mauvais temps qui
retardait les parachutages
d'approvisionnement la division
aéroportée subissaient les contre
attaques salma
le 25 septembre à court de munitions et
sachant que les renforts étaient trop
loin pour les aider les anglais font
pire le combat et tentèrent de rejoindre
les lignes rallye
[Musique]
sur plus de dix mille hommes engagés à
arnhem seulement 2827 survécu
[Musique]
au début d'octobre 1944 les alliés
s'approchait d'aix la chapelle
la ville était défendu par trois
divisions de grenadiers et une division
d'infanterie sous le commandement du
général d'infanterie frédéric gauch lire
ses troupes n'avaient pas encore été
engagée dans des actions majeures
mais elle était déjà affaibli par les
efforts désespérés pour empêcher les
alliés de traverser la ligne siegfried
le 7 octobre les alliés attaquèrent à 12
km au nord de la ville tentant de
l'encercler et de percer par l'aïe
pour les défenseurs la tentative de
conserver ex en tant que citadel nazi
semblait déjà désespérée
cependant les forces allemandes
tentèrent de contre-attaqué pour
contenir la vence alliés suffisamment
longtemps afin de permettre aux
divisions blindées de von rundstedt de
mobiliser ses réserves
mais cela n'arrivera pas
le haut commandement allemand avait déjà
décidé ex était définitivement perdue et
qu'il n'était pas nécessaire d'y lancer
en pure perte de précieuses unités
blindées
les alliés mirent la pression sur le sud
autour de vues réelles m à quelques 5 km
d'aix
le mur de l'ouest commençait à montrer
des signes d'effondrement
[Musique]
le 10 octobre les alliés se regroupèrent
sur les collines surplombant ex l'achat
les allemands étaient maintenant coincé
entre deux fronts
et les alliés resserraient leurs filets
autour de la ville
le commandant de la garnison allemande
reçu alors un ultimatum
s'il ne capitulait pas sans condition
dans les 24 heures
les américains pulvériserait la ville à
coups de bombes et de tirs d'artillerie
puis prendrait la ville où ceux qui en
resterait par un assaut terrestre
les 24 heures s'écoulent r&i l'assaut
final fut lance
les zones industrielles dans le faux
furent les premiers à tourner
au nord de la ville la 30e division us
se rapprocher
je
il
[Musique]
les combats qui éclatèrent dans les
faubourgs pris une tournure inquiétante
car les allemands résister farouchement
pour chaque mètre de terrain cédé aux
ailes
pendant ce temps le 21e groupe blindée
britannique sous le commandement de
montgomery avancée des rangs vers plus
au nord
le terrain constitué de grands champs
agricoles permettait aux blindés de
tracer facilement leur route jusqu'aux
forêts impénétrables et au collet
les défenses allemandes était puissante
et les soldats allemands qui
combattaient alors pour leur patrie et
les disciplines et c'était de
fantastique combattants les pertes aux
alliés augmentait sans cesse
[Musique]
après cinq semaines de siège à aix les
troupes us finalement pénétrèrent dans
la ville le 13 octobre se frayant un
chemin vers le centre à travers les
ruines et les immeubles effondrés
[Musique]
la ville avait été victime non seulement
deux là soient liés mais aussi des moins
de campagne de bombardements par la
royal air force
des 165 mille habitants qu'elle comptait
avant la guerre un peu moins de 20
milles seulement y habitait encore
les snipers allemand tenait les greniers
pour les cavs
[Musique]
les américains furent alors bloqué dans
un premier temps par des barricades
fortement défendu
les soldats mesurer les gains sur le
terrain en termes d'immeubles des taj et
même de pièces
les combats à l'est de pire en pire et
était de plus en plus dangereux
les allemands s'abritaient ce cachet
comme ils le pouvaient dans les
immeubles dans des bureaux dans des
appartements
une fois que les soldats us était passée
il lançait des attaques sur leur arrière
la ville devait être fouillé
intégralement et méticuleusement aucun
immeuble ne pouvait être négligée
le 19 octobre l'auberge de bilkent
commandant de ce qu'il restait deux
allemandes donnent à ses ordres
les combattants d'aix doivent se
préparer à leur dernière bataille
retranché dans le plus petit espace
possible nous allons devoir combattre
jusqu'au dernier soldat le dernier au
but et la dernière balle en accord avec
les ordres du führer
en dépit de trahison commises par
certains j'attends que tous les
défenseurs de la vénérable cité
impériale d'aix la chapelle fassent leur
devoir jusqu'à la fin
dans l'accomplissement de notre serment
à notre drapeau nous vous souhaitons
courage et détermination pour tenir
longue vie au führer et à notre patrie
bien aimé
les défenseurs d'aix furent abandonnées
et laissés à leur sort les derniers se
rendirent le 21 octobre
[Musique]
un peu plus au nord les britanniques
combattent est durement et commencer
leurs attaques sur l'est de la rivière
marne il s'agissait ensuite de passer à
l'étape suivante foncer vers le rhin
l'allemagne était dans l'obligation de
défendre ses frontières sur les deux
fronts
[Musique]
il
la puissante line sigfried ou murs de
l'ouest la dernière défense allemande
avait cédé tout ce qu'il en restait
n'étaient que des bris et casemates
effondré
les alliés étaient désormais sur le sol
allemand et les jours du régime nazi
était compté
[Musique]
tout au long de la ligne siegfried
soldats alliés planter leur drapeau et
préparer le passage pour l'assaut final
contre la forteresse allemagne
le premier ministre britannique winston
churchill s'envola pour venir constater
par lui même
il connaissait tous les risques et
l'immense responsabilité de lancer tant
d'hommes dans un tel assaut
beaucoup de choses auraient pu mal
tourner pendant cette période c'est à
dire depuis le mois de juin et personne
plus que lui n'en était aussi conscient
quelques 29 ans plus tôt lors de la
première guerre mondiale des milliers de
britanniques et de soldats de l'anp pire
avaient péri sous le feu des
mitrailleuses alors qu'il touchait terre
sur l'épreuve du calibre
comme premier lord de l'amirauté à cette
époque il avait pris la responsabilité
de ces pertes et avait subi de vêtements
reproche
le général eisenhower commandant suprême
de la force expéditionnaire alliés pour
le débarquement de normandie
constata également les brèches dans la
ligne siegfried lors de l'hiver 1944
sous son indiscutable autorités les
alliés ont traversé la france pour
atteindre les frontières allemandes
bousculant les troupes nazies sans leur
laisser la chance de se ressaisir
[Musique]
il s'était fait l'avocat d'une attaque
de l'allemagne sur un large front une
tactique qui s'était déjà avérée payante
13 décembre la ville de metz tomber et
eisenhower ordonna alors à ses troupes
pour faire diversion d'attaquer le flanc
sud et d'avancé sur le rhin
[Musique]
le 22 mars 1945 après un hiver long et
meurtrier la troisième armée traversait
finalement le rhin
1 et au gigantesque était en train de se
refermer sur le troisième reich
le fleuve était le dernier obstacle
naturel majeur entre les alliés et le
coeur de l'allemagne
une fois traversé les armées alliées se
ruèrent sur les ruines du troisième
reich et encerclèrent son coeur
industriel la vallée de l'arroux
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
elle
hitler avait promis au peuple allemand
l'invincibilité
il leur avait promis un troisième reich
qui durait milan
il avait tenu plus
le troisième reich n'a rien laissé en
héritage
si ce ne sont les conséquences
géographique et politique de la plus
terrible guerre de l'histoire
à une seule exception
un monument de métal et de béton qui
existe encore de nos jours
[Musique]
la ligne siegfried a contenu les armées
alliées et prolonger la guerre de sept
mois
[Musique]
elle fut finalement submergés sous le
nom
les pertes alliées pour passer le mur
furent plus importantes que celles
subies en corée et au vietnam
[Musique]
là où hitler et ses généraux avaient
marché poussé par l'admiration du peuple
allemand il n'y a plus maintenant que
les traces de pas d'une armée
victorieuse qui fut capable de mettre un
point final un drame qui ébranla la
planète
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh